c'est un mec qui rentre dans une
animalerie et il dit bonjour monsieur je
vais me est-ce que j'aimerais avoir un
chien de garde un Molos vraiment un
chien qui fait peur il dit il n'y a pas
de souci monsieur regardez j'ai ce petit
caniche à vous proposer vous foutez de
ma gueule ou quoi je viens de vous dire
je veux un chien de garde il dit mais
vous rendez pas compte c'est pas un
caniche comme les autres ça c'est un
caniche qui fait du karaté d'ailleurs
c'est son prénom et ça s'appelle karaté
et pour l'activer vous dites deux fois
de karaté et il fera casse tout ce qui
bouge tiens vous voyez pour voir karaté
karaté porte
[Rires]
tu vois c'est impressionnant je peux
essayer essayer karaté karaté ta table
fracasse la table monsieur c'est parfait
j'achète ce petit chien il rentre chez
lui chez ses potes le soir et ses potes
il lui dit alors tu l'as acheté ce chien
il dit voilà le petit caniche ça les
gars il dit c'est quoi ce chien vous
êtes malade ou quoi ça c'est un chien
qui fait du karaté et un pote il dit
ouais karaté karaté mes couilles
[Applaudissements]
c'est deux amis folles bien mytho il
doit avoir un verre comme ça et l'autre
il lui dit alors tu as fait quoi hier et
du bon rien si si enfin j'étais un
moment j'étais chez moi j'ai voulu une
entrecôte et donc j'ai appelé le riche
j'aurais dit les gars c'est David
préparer moi la chambre 505 la plus
belle je veux une entrecôte je suis
morte il arrive je commence à manger un
peu et bon il y avait pas de moutarde
donc je leur ai demandé la moutarde mais
j'avais pas la moutarde comme j'aime de
Dijon donc j'ai appelé le Bourget et je
leur ai dit avancer le jet j'arrive je
vais chercher la moutarde et bref bon et
toi qu'est-ce que tu as fait non moi
j'étais en boîte hier
j'ai posé une bouteille la plus belle
bouteille et là à côté de moi il y a à
Kim Kardashian qui a posé une bouteille
à côté de moi et tout et je vois quand
même comment ça me chauffer comme ça
elle veut danser on commence à chauffer
pas et à l'oreille comment ça me dit
elle croit que je crois pas en anglais
elle me dit i want sex with you comment
[Musique]
je l'ai pris ramener chez moi
bref on s'éclate on se met sur le lit on
fume une clope comme ça elle reçoit un
FaceTime qui reçoit le FaceTime de
[Musique]
chez moi
[Rires]
Rihanna et bien chez moi les de Rihanna
kim Kardashian
c'est quoi cette soirée fous pourquoi tu
m'as pas appelé déjà appelé chez toi
j'ai ta mère elle m'a répondu mais tu
étais à Dijon frère
c'est de juifs qui ont un petit litige
financier pour changer d'avis emocher
donc ils vont aller voir le grand rabbin
pour régler le problème David il parlera
pas il dit voilà Monsieur le rabat on a
un problème avec Moshi voilà on veut
savoir est-ce que pour vous la couleur
noire est-ce que c'est considéré dans la
Torah dans le est-ce que c'est considéré
comme une couleur et dit mes enfants moi
quand on pose une question je dois aller
me retirer dans mon bureau je vais
étudier et je vous donnerai la réponse
quoi il va dans son bureau il étudie il
étudie il revient il dit bon j'ai trouvé
la réponse oui d'après Laura
d'après les enseignements qu'on a eu la
couleur noire
qu'à proprement parler une couleur
d'accord et le blanc maintenant le blanc
est-ce que le blanc c'est une couleur il
dit oui bah pareil je vais aller étudier
il va il étudie
bon mes enfants voilà pareil j'ai la
réponse est que son frère cadeau je m'en
fous il nous dit que oui le blanc c'est
une couleur comme le noir les deux sont
des couleurs et David virus retourne
vers Moshi tu vois que je t'ai vendu une
télé en couleur
c'est enfin j'ai pas un petit déj avec
sa femme et sa femme elle lui dit tu
sais que mon amour tu sais quel jour on
est aujourd'hui comment bien sûr c'est
nos 35 ans de mariage quoi tu t'en es
souvenu mon amour bien sûr 35 ans je
m'en souviens alors mon cœur je peux
poser une question pourquoi en 35 ans de
mariage tu m'as jamais rien acheté il
dit pourquoi tu as quelque chose à
vendre
ces trois mecs qui meurent ils arrivent
devant l'éternel le premier il arrive
devant et l'Éternel lui dit bon bah si
on fait le point sur ta vie voilà bravo
tu as une belle femme des beaux enfants
tu as donné l'argent aux pauvres tu as
même rendu visite au malade mais [__]
tu as une maîtresse pendant 15 ans 15
ans c'est trop chinette et vas-y
casse-toi là le deuxième il arrive et
toi je suis pareil sublime une belle
femme tes beaux enfants tu les as élevés
dans la spiritualité j'ai entendu tes
prières jusqu'ici tu m'as prié avec
dévotion bravo et [__] tu as eu 15
maîtresses tiens prends cette
trottinette et tu te casses le dernier
il arrive et dis-toi par contre parfait
des beaux enfants tu les élever dans les
spiritualité tu as donné de l'argent aux
pauvres tu as rendu visiter malade et tu
n'as jamais trompé ta femme une seule
fois tu apprends cette Ferrari il va te
balader dans les contrées du paradis
il prend la Ferrari se balade il se
balade il se met sur le côté il s'arrête
et il pleure il pleure il pleure là il y
a les deux mecs en trottinette ils se
mettent à côté lui mais pourquoi tu
pleures il dit non j'ai vu ma femme
toute façon en trottinette
c'est le mec qui marche dans la rue et
sans faire exprès il marche il tape dans
un carton et là il y a un génie qui sort
waouh je suis le génie du carton j'ai
l'homme tu as le droit ça existe
pas du tout moi des génies là là
monsieur vous avez taper dans le carton
tu as le droit venant et pas c'est quoi
ta boisson préférée il va le pastis ben
déjà un pisse du pastis
rentre chez lui d'ici il a pas le
serveur chérie prépare de verre j'arrive
et dis quoi prépare de r il arrive du
pastis tapéro le lendemain il est au
bureau il dit attends peut-être ça
remarche du pastis j'irai chéri prépare
de verre j'arrive tac tac tous les jours
prépare de ben j'arrive un jour il
appelle chérie prépare un verre il a dit
je vois pas c'est ici mais ce soir tu
bois au boulot
c'est une grande société avec plein
d'employés et la DRH avoir le boss il
dit on a un problème on a trop
d'employés il va falloir enfin il y a
nous en France il faut engager des
handicapés quoi bah ok bah faites des
entretiens donc il y a plein d'endicapés
qui passent qui passent et là il y a un
mec qui arrive plutôt
pas d'handicap il marche bien il parle
bien même plutôt beau gosse elle dit
mais monsieur excuse-moi c'est quoi
votre handicap à vous il y a aussi moi
je suis un ancien militaire moi j'arrive
du Mali là et j'ai marché sur une mine
et puis j'ai plus de couilles il y a
plus rien quoi donc sinon tout le reste
marche très très bien ok bah vous êtes
engagé quoi bon venez demain à 11h ça
commence pas à 9h chez vous d'ici mais
pour vous c'est mieux que vous venez à
11h non mais madame vous voyez bien que
j'ai pas d'handicap ok c'est si les
autres ils commencent à 9h je viens à 9h
non 9h 11h 9h 11h un an et demi mais
pourquoi vous voulez pas que je vienne à
9h et dis parce que dans cette boîte de
9 heures à 11h on a l'habitude de se
gratter un peu les couilles
dans un bar il est bourré archi bourré
mort il dit ouais vas-y je rentre chez
moi il fait de pas et pas Fiton par
terre c'est pas possible je suis pas
mort à ce point je vais ramper au moins
jusqu'à dehors je vais prendre l'air
frais peut-être ça va me relancer il
rampe dehors il prend l'air frais il se
lève il marche de pas et paf il tombe
par terre encore et je suis mort à ce
point je vais je vais empêcher jusqu'à
chez moi heureusement il habite à 300
mètres tirant Piran pirent il prend sa
serrure il tombe il tourne il ouvre la
porte il me fait 2 m et pas il tombe
encore il dit mais qu'est-ce que j'ai vu
c'est pas possible il rampe il montre
les escaliers jusqu'à son lit il se met
dans son lit il s'endort d'épuisement de
fatigue il a rampé trois ça peut être
comme ça il dort alors demain sa femme
elle avait dit [__] Gérard tu étais
encore bourré au bar hier je comment tu
sais comment je sais il y a pas trop du
bar il vient d'appeler tu as encore
oublié ton fauteuil roul ant j'ai
un mec qui rentre dans un bar il est
déjà bourré et dit bonjour je peux pas
un whisky avant que ça commence
qui dit whisky franchement ça commence
monsieur attends je comprends pas vous
dites à whisky je comprends mais
qu'est-ce que vous dites à la fin du nom
là mais c'est juste
45 commence
on vous embrasse monsieur Bigard et il
faut savoir
8000 2000 euros 5000 euros vous vendez
pas compte messieurs dames c'est une
vache qui a été ainsi mis
artificiellement c'est à dire que
lorsqu'elle va mettre bas elle ne va pas
mettre bas un seul veau mais cinq mots
c'est 5 pour le prix d'un 10000 euros
12000 €, le potiron je la vends plus la
vache et pourquoi pas frère si elle a
toutes les options je la garde
[Applaudissements]